watching children in early adolescence
and in adolescence is is always
eternally heartbreaking for adults there
was a great article in The Times
Magazine about Christmas maybe 20 years
ago that the power of the Christmas
mystery is when you look at a child the
same way that you know in the story that
the Virgin Mary looked at her they
looked at her new son the Christ child
and thought simultaneously this child
might save the world and he's going to
die right so this like huge amount of
hope we have for our children and this
terror that they're gonna die if my
mother looked at me at 13 if she read my
Diaries about how eagerly I wanted to be
popular it would sound very like someone
courting likes on Instagram you know I
knew if my outfit didn't go over well
and I knew the way that a 13 year old
might not post a photo might pull down a
photograph of it on Instagram if it
doesn't get enough likes not to wear
that again right or I decided not to
wear that again because being liked was
the most important thing in the world to
me at that age and for a reason you want
to know how you're gonna play in the
world you want to know how to be in the
world how to show up in the world and
you're testing and learning what works
for you and by the way it's heartbreak
breaking it's heartbreaking when people
don't like you or invite you to a party
and similarly it's heartbreaking you
know now when you don't get the response
you crave online or you get a response
that's out of proportion to what you did
but you know taking the risk of let's
just take the simple you know Instagram
brings up fears of narcissism because
we're in heyday of self portraiture
which we've been in before there have
been other times where people you know
sat for portraits or painted themselves
and you know van Gogh's self-portrait is
rarely regarded as a work of narcissism
but let's say that we have this popular
form that as these self-portraits
staging them taking the photograph
taking many photographs choosing the
right photograph cropping it coloring it
and then distributing it immediately -
you know this giant gallery space and
then like every artist trying to see who
buys it trying to see who's interested
trying to see if it sells and trying to
see what kind of commentary they get on
it you know a lot of people who post
self-portraits and this was true in the
early days of YouTube with musicians are
actually looking in some cases for
critical feedback you know remember the
hot-or-not thing where you put
photographs were posted and you could
decide I like I don't like that you know
which also plays on the right and left
swipe of tinder is sometimes what
recording like does this work does this
work I'm in beta right now you know do I
talk loud enough do I talk too loud do
you know that credible
self-consciousness of like are my bangs
a little too short are my eyes big
enough or you know how can I inhabit
this body that I'm in and be and fit the
exigencies of social life fit the
exigent exigencies of a party or a
workspace or by the way opt out of it
you know there are plenty of kids who
are dialing back and we see among
Millennials a return to flip phones or
to abstinence from computers from from
the internet and I think that's very
interesting the last thing I'll say you
know when you talk about teaching my own
kids I feel very strongly that we can't
adopt a True Love Waits abstinence
program about screens the idea is not to
teach your kids you know never go to
parties never live in social space avoid
other people we like learning to live in
digital space is not unlike learning to
live in social space and it's what kids
want help doing you know I remember my
mother teaching me this incredibly
subtle social lesson which is when
you're describing a party that you went
to but another friend didn't get invited
to don't say the party was terrible
don't say they missed nothing don't say
it was awful it's disingenuous it's not
it's not fair to the host and it's
condescending to the person you're
talking to
anything that you were left out of was
awful right so I you know I metabolized
that lesson I remember it was a
sleepover and I was eight years old
those are the kind of lessons you teach
your kids online are you gonna be the
kind of person that posts a topless shot
on Instagram well that has certain
requirements that's going to have
certain consequences let's go through
those consequences are if you if you are
you gonna be post in all caps say are
you gonna use Twitter a lot or you can
use Pinterest a lot if you use Pinterest
what are you gonna use it for what is
the Buy button about well how much are
you using this as to tee up
purchases and what are you gonna do with
that debt how are you gonna afford those
things what are you gonna do with the
part of the internet that shows your
credit card debt say these are
experiences that ought to be embraced
with confidence ought to be embraced
with confidence not as though the party
the people the city streets that
whatever are simply terrifying and the
only thing to do is lock your door
against them but to show up with you
know yeah you know the women I know got
advice from their mother that's too much
black eyeliner you know that's too much
hair dye you know getting a I remember
when I pierced my ear the second time my
mother said that's prelude to getting a
tattoo I didn't agree with her right I
didn't agree with her I decided to that
I would do it anyway and wear a second
earring in that year and that was okay
but there are certain things that you
say to your kid like you know my son
just chose his his his gmail name right
and he decided to use his whole name
like his first middle and last name
because it showed up you know no one
else had it and that is a lot of letters
to type in he's got a long name to type
into Gmail all this time and I asked him
you may have a lifetime of signing into
things with your gmail address do you
really want to be typing all those
letters he said yes
when he chose his avatar for Google he
took a million pictures of himself he's
ten years old and he opted to have one
of those executive pictures leaning way
back for lots of like authority and
alpha-male nests and I asked him you're
10 years old don't you want to be like a
little cuter and more childlike and he
said absolutely not I'm going with the
executive picture and that was a good
strategic decision for him I think a
good artistic decision for him you know
empowering our kids to think like
artists to think like writers to think
like novelists they are creating an
avatar online you don't want to be like
you don't necessarily want to be some
Pollyanna avatar who only posts great
things about her life maybe you do or
do you show up all the time vague
booking and writing sad-sack posts and
talking you know really vulnerably like
a memoirist maybe you know maybe but
those are choices that have consequences
and that's at that level of detail
because by the way we all do it in our
lives with Facebook anyway that level of
detail you teach kids
[Music]